heute am 25 07 2009 10 war soweit der
allzeitrekord in deutschland wurde
geknackt im niedersächsischen lingen
wurden 42,6 grad celsius gemessen der
höchste temperatur wert seit beginn der
wetteraufzeichnungen noch im weltweiten
vergleich sind das echte peanuts
unvorstellbare heiße 56 7 grad celsius
wurden beispielsweise 1913 im
kalifornischen death valley gemessen und
auch die anderen weltrekorde lassen
einen einfach nur noch staunen egal ob
es um den meisten schnee in 24 stunden
geht oder aber um die größten
hagelkörner die je auf die erde geprallt
sind krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinieren des
rheins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasste nichts herzlich
willkommen und bevor wir direkt mit dem
wetter rekorden staaten eine sache vorab
alle daten beziehen sich natürlich nicht
auf die ganze menschheitsgeschichte
sondern auch die zeit seitdem es moderne
wetteraufzeichnungen gibt auf platz fünf
die dicksten hagelkörner die je auf die
erde prasselten wenn warme und kalte
luftschichten aufeinandertreffen und
eispartikel durch aufwände lange in der
schwebe gehalten werden entsteht hagel
das wasser gefriert also in unterkühlten
gewitterwolken die immer wieder nach
oben gerissen werden und so anwachsen
mutter meteorologie experten und
expertinnen spricht man aber erst von
nagel wenn der durchmesser der eiskörner
einen halben zentimeter überschreitet
alles was kleiner ist wird als graupel
bezeichnet über dem ammersee vielen
anfang juni 2009 10 bis zu sechs
zentimeter dicke hagelkörner
es schien so als würde der see kochen
denn auf den ersten blick schien es so
als würden tausende fontänen aus der
wasseroberfläche herausschießen wie
heißer dampf doch es war nur vage und
die hagelkörner waren allerdings so groß
wie golfbälle und die schäden waren
enorm boote wurden verbeult und
autoscheiben durchschlagen krasse bilder
die aber nichts gegen den leistungen
sind der am 23 juli 2010 in south dakota
vom himmel herunter gegen genaugenommen
traf es die stadt wie viren
der brocken hier hatte einen
unglaublichen durchmesser von 20
zentimetern und einen umfang von 7
sich zentimetern lebensbedrohlich waren
aber auch die offiziellen rekordhalter
die in banger der schneelage kamen ein
kilogramm schwere geschosse die am 14
april ist seit 86
insgesamt 92 todesopfer forderten platz
vier
der stärkste sturm auf der erde das sind
wirklich extremen naturgewalten die
wirbelstürme der subtropen und tropen
mit dem gepäck haben sie nämlich
unangenehme begleiterscheinungen wie
dauerregen und extreme brandung an den
küsten trauriger rekordhalter in dieser
kategorie ist der taifun tipp der im
jahr 1979 die küste der japanischen
insel honshu traf er forderte 86
todesopfer und zerstörte auch häuser
schlimm genug auch dafür dass es sich
hierbei um den heftigsten stärksten und
größten tropischen wirbelsturm gehandelt
hat hielten sich seine folgen dann
jedoch noch in grenzen denn seine
ausmaße waren wirklich unvorstellbar
sein maximaler durchmesser lag bei 2200
kilometern
der gemessene luftdruck in seinem auge
lag bei 870 milliarden weiterer sehr
extremer zyklon der wettergeschichte
zerstörte 2013 weise teile der
philippinen unseres tausende menschen
mit in den tod
wurde auch als der supersturm der
moderne bezeichnet denn seine extremen
windböen erreichten geschwindigkeiten
von bis zu 3 179 kilometern pro stunde
so zählt seit jahren zu den vier
stärksten je gemessenen wirbelsturm der
welt platz drei
der meiste schnee in 24 stunden an
dieser stelle ist es gar nicht so
einfach genaue angaben zu machen denn es
gibt nicht wirklich einen weltweiten
standard zur erfassung von schnee fällt
doch es gibt langjährige
beobachtungsraum zumindest aus japan
kanada und den usa in europa wird
dagegen gemessen um wie viel flüssigkeit
es sich handelt wenn der schnee schmilzt
dennoch gibt es ein rekordalter wenn
auch nur inoffiziell es handelt sich um
das kleine dorf capra cotta in italien
denn am fünften märz 2015 hat es der
schnee hier innerhalb von 24 stunden auf
250 zentimeter zweieinhalb meter
gebracht allerdings ist dieser wert
offiziell nicht anerkannt skeptiker
sprechen eher von so 80 zentimetern in
24 stunden
aber auch das ist nicht
wenn man sich einen längeren zeitraum an
schaut nämlich den eingang eines ganzen
winters ist das strato vulkan mount
becker in washington spitzenreiter 29
meter schnee hatte sich hier im winter
1989 90 angesammelt platz zwei die
extremste je gemessene uv-strahlung mit
den werten des sogenannten v gefahren
index sollen die risiken beim aufenthalt
in der sonne besser eingeschätzt werden
können
denn klar ist die ultraviolette
strahlung kann gesundheitsgefährdend
sein denn sie schädigt beispielsweise
die erbsubstanz der menschen
ein uv index von sechs bis sieben zählt
bereits als hoch und die strahlung der
sonne ist dann so hoch dass die haut
schutz braucht damit schäden vermieden
werden können doch diese werte sind
wirklich peanuts im vergleich zu den
index spitzenwerten die ein
internationales forschungsteam in den
jahren 2003 und 2004 in den anden
boliviens gemessen hatte ein
unglaublicher index spitzenwert von 43,3
ein solcher extremer wert wurde sonst
noch nie auf der erde gemessen rekord
also dazu die wissenschaftlerin natalie
kabul wenn der index ein wert von 30 bis
40 erreichen will und sollte man sich am
besten nicht mehr draußen aufhalten dass
dieser rekord überhaupt aufgestellt
wurde wurde wohl durch mehrere faktoren
begünstigt zum einen durch die sehr
dünne höhenluft den knapp sechs
kilometern höhe
denn dort in der stratosphäre ist
weniger ozon vorhanden dass die
uv-b-strahlung herausfiltert zudem stand
die sonne nach ihrem zenit und weiterhin
trugen auch unwetter und saisonaler
waldbrände zu dem rekordwert bei dadurch
ozon abgebaut wird auch durch eine
vorausgegangene sonneneruption waren
bestimmte teilchen namens aerosole in
der atmosphäre die dafür verantwortlich
gemacht werden schützende ozon moleküle
zu zerstören auf platz eins die
krasseste temperaturschwankungen kurzer
zeit das ist wirklich kaum vorstellbar
innerhalb von nur zwei minuten stiegen
in einem kleinen dorf im us bundesstaat
süd dakota die temperaturen von minus 20
grad celsius achtung auf 8,3 grad
celsius plus
wow das ist wirklich ein
rekordverdächtiger temperaturanstieg in
super kurzer zeit verantwortlich dafür
ein warmer fallwind mit der bezeichnung
china den man sie
so ähnlich vorstellen kann wie die
föhnwinde in den alpen auch die
entstehung eines solchen schien ucs ist
vergleichbar feuchte wände werden durch
das gebirge nach oben geleitet und
kühlen dabei ab die luftfeuchtigkeit
kondensiert und das ist der grund warum
es an der westseite der rocky mountains
oft zu extremen schneefällen kommt die
luftströmung die an der ostseite wieder
absteigt erwärmt sich genau das hat dann
die extremen temperaturschwankungen zur
folge charakteristisch für den
winterlichen genug ist seine
unbeständigkeit wenn die fallwinde
aussetzen kommt es wieder zu eisigen
temperaturen
so war es auch am besagten 22 januar
1943 nach dem um 37 am morgen die
temperaturen von minus 20 grad auf plus
8,3 grad celsius angestiegen waren
erfolgte zunächst ein weiterer anstieg
auf 12 grad bis 9 uhr morgens doch dann
setzten die fallwinde aus und innerhalb
von 27 minuten sanken die temperaturen
wieder herunter auf den morgendlichen
tiefpunkt droht in den städten jetzt der
hitzetod denn solche extremereignisse
haben natürlich mit dem klimawandel zu
tun und da steigen in den städten die
durchschnittlichen temperaturen in den
nächsten jahren da geht es in diesem
video anklicken anschauen und krieg zum
nature abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran